le chatelier's principle says if a
stress is applied to a reaction mixture
at equilibrium the net reaction goes in
the direction that relieves the stress
changing the concentration of a reactant
or product is one way to place a stress
on a reaction at equilibrium
for example let's consider the reaction
the hypothetical reaction where gas a
turns into gas b
and let's say the reaction is at
equilibrium and we suddenly introduce a
stress such as we increase the
concentration of reactant a
according to le chatelier's principle
the
the net reaction is going to go in the
direction that relieves the stress and
since we increase the concentration of a
the net reaction is going to go to the
right to decrease the concentration of a
let's use some particulate diagram so we
can get into the details of how the
reaction goes to the right so we're
going to symbolize gas a by red
particles and gas b by blue particles
and for this hypothetical reaction the
equilibrium constant is equal to 3 at 25
degrees celsius
let's start by writing the reaction
quotient qc
is equal to and we get that from our
balanced equation that would be the
concentration of b to the first power
divided by the concentration of a also
to the first power
let's calculate the concentrations of b
and a from our first particular diagram
so b is represented by the blue spheres
and there are three blue spheres if each
particle represents 0.1 moles of a
substance and the volume of the
container is one liter since we have
three particles that'll be three times
0.1 which is 0.3 moles divided by a
volume of 1 liter is 0.3 molar so the
concentration of b is 0.3 molar
for a we have one particle so that's 0.1
mole divided by 1 liter which is 0.1
molar so the concentration of a is 0.1
molar
and point three divided by point one is
equal to three so qc at this moment in
time is equal to three
notice we could have just counted our
particles three blues and one red and
said three over one that would have been
a little bit faster
so qc is equal to 3
and kc is also equal to 3 so i should
have written a c in here so when qc is
equal to kc the reaction is at
equilibrium so in this first particulate
diagram here where qc is equal to kc
the reaction's at equilibrium
next we're going to introduce a stress
to our reaction at equilibrium we're
going to increase the concentration of a
so here we're going to add four
particles of a to the reaction mixture
at equilibrium
the second particulate diagram shows
what the reaction looks like right after
we add those four red particles so we
start with one red particle and we added
four so now there's a total of five red
particles and we still have the same
three blue particles that we had in the
first particular diagram
let's calculate qc at this moment in
time so just after we introduce the
stress
since there are three blue particles and
five red particles qc is equal to three
divided by five which is equal to 0.6
since qc is equal to 0.6 and kc is equal
to 3
at this moment in time qc is less than
kc so there are too many reactants and
not enough products therefore the net
reaction is going to go to the right and
we're going to decrease in the amount of
a
and we're going to increase in the
amount of b
the third particular diagram shows what
happens after the net reaction moves to
the right so we said we're going to
decrease the amount of a and increase in
the amount of b
we're going from three blues in the
second particular diagram to six blues
in the third
and we're going from we're going from
five reds to only two reds
therefore three reds must have turned
into blues to get the third particular
diagram on the right and if we calculate
qc for our third particulate diagram
would be equal to six divided by two
which is equal to three
so at this moment in time qc is equal to
kc they're both equal to three so
equilibrium has been re-established in
the third particular diagram
it isn't always necessary to calculate q
values when doing a le chatelier
changing concentration problem however
for this hypothetical reaction it's it's
useful to calculate q values to
understand that we're starting at
equilibrium and then a stress is
introduced such as changing the
concentration of a reactant or product
and that means the reaction is no longer
at equilibrium the schalke's principle
allows us to predict which direction the
net reaction will will go
or we could also use q to predict the
direction of the net reaction the net
reaction will continue going in that new
direction until q is equal to k again
and equilibrium has been re-established
let's look at another reaction this is
the synthesis of ammonia from nitrogen
gas and hydrogen gas
let's say the reaction is at equilibrium
so let's also look at this on a graph of
concentration versus time at equilibrium
the concentrations of reactants and
products are constant which is why we
see these straight lines here for the
concentration of hydrogen ammonia and
nitrogen
and let's introduce a stress to the
system at equilibrium so right now we
are at equilibrium and all the
concentrations are constant and let's
increase the concentration of hydrogen
so we can see that on our graph
so right here there's a sudden increase
in the concentration of hydrogen
adding hydrogen means that q is no
longer equal to k and therefore the
reaction is not at equilibrium so let's
go ahead and write over here
now we're not at equilibrium
and the shot layers principle allows us
to predict which direction the net
reaction will move so since we added a
stress the stress of being the stress
being increased concentration of
hydrogen the net reaction is going to
move to the right to get rid of some of
that hydrogen that was added
and when the reaction goes to the right
the amount of ammonia will increase and
that's what we can see right here on
this red line here the amount of ammonia
is increasing
and the amount of ammonia increases
because nitrogen and hydrogen are
reacting to form ammonia therefore the
amount of nitrogen and hydrogen will
decrease here we can see the amount of
hydrogen is decreasing and down here we
can see the amount of nitrogen is
decreasing
the reaction will continue to go to the
right until equilibrium is
re-established and that happens at the
second dotted line here and we know that
because we can see all of these
concentrations are now constant so the
reaction has reached equilibrium
so far we've only talked about changing
the concentration of a reactant so for
example if we increase the concentration
of hydrogen the net reaction goes to the
right we could also say shifts to the
right so for a reaction at equilibrium
if you increase the concentration of
reactants such as the concentration of
hydrogen or the concentration of
nitrogen
the reaction will shift to the right to
decrease the amount of one of those
reactants
and if our reaction is at equilibrium
and we were to increase the amount of
our product to increase the amount of
ammonia so this time the stress places
increased concentration of a product the
shortlist principle says the net
reaction is going to move in the
direction that decreases the stress so
in this case and that reaction would go
to the left to decrease the amount of
ammonia
and if our reaction is at equilibrium
and we were to decrease the
concentration of our product
the net reaction would shift to the
right to make more of the product
or if we decrease the concentration of
one of our reactants let's say of of
nitrogen in this case the reaction will
shift to the left to make more of our
reactant